AND DANA PERINO.
IN A NORMAL WORLD WHEN YOU DO
SOMETHING THAT WORKS LIKE MAKING
PROGRESS ON THE BORDER PEOPLE
MIGHT SAY, "GOOD JOB" BUT THIS
ISN'T A NORMAL WORLD.
>> YOU CAN'T HAVE A TRADE POLICY
BASED ON TWEETS.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
COMPLETELY OVERBLOWN WHAT HE
PURPORTS TO HAVE ACHIEVED.
>> I CONTINUE TO THINK THAT
FOREIGN LEADERS MUST LOOK AT
THIS PRESIDENCY IN THE WAY WE
USED TO LOOK AT, PARTICULARLY
UNSTABLE REGIMES.
>> IT'S A PATTERN WE HAVE SEEN
REPEATEDLY WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
HE SORT OF CREATES A CRISIS, HAS
SOME SORT OF A FAIRLY GENERAL
RESOLUTION TO IT THAT'S LACKING
ANY DETAILS AND THEN DECLARES
VICTORY.
>> Greg: BETO CALLING SOMETHING
OVERBLOWN.
THAT'S LIKE DE BLASIO CALLING
YOU UNPOPULAR.
IF TRUMP DISCOVERED A CURE FOR
DEATH THEY WOULD ACCUSE HIM OF
PUTTING GRAVEDIGGERS OUT OF
BUSINESS.
IT'S WEIRD WHEN SOMEONE LOOKS AT
SOMETHING PRODUCTIVE AND CALLS
IT COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
A BELT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
KEEPING YOUR PANTS UP.
BORDER ENFORCEMENT IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO A STRONG
BORDER.
BUT YOU CAN'T TRUST PEOPLE IF
THEY CAN'T ADMIT OBVIOUS
RESULTS.
IT MEANS THE RESPONSES ARE
EMOTIONAL DELUSIONS.
TAKE ME.
I WAS A CRITIC OF TRUMP FOR A
LONG TIME AND I HATED TARIFFS
BUT I'VE GOT TO ADMIT THERE IS
SOMETHING TO THEM THAT I MISSED
AND IT'S USHERING IN A NEW WAY
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT STILL SEE
MILITARY SOLUTIONS AS SUPERIOR
TO FINANCIAL ONES.
WHEN EVERY TIME TRUMP THREATENS
A TARIFF AND MEANS IT, MAYBE
THAT'S ONE LESS PROBLEM SOLVED
BY VIOLENCE.
TRUMP WAGES WAR WITH
MATHEMATICS, NOT MEN.
SHOULDN'T LEFTIES LOVE THAT?
ISN'T THAT PROGRESS?
WHICH IS TWO PARTS OF THAT WORD
"PROGRESSIVE"?
ACCORDING TO THE COUNCIL ON
FOREIGN RELATIONS THE WEST IS
FREE OF CONFLICT NOT INCLUDING
THE DRUG WAR.
TO QUOTE HUMANPROGRESS.ORG, NO
PERSON ALIVE CAN REMEMBER OUR
WESTERN HEMISPHERE TO BE AS
PEACEFUL AS IT IS TODAY.
THAT'S AMAZING.
WHAT DO YOU SAY, DEMOCRATS IN
THE MEDIA?
THAT IS A GREAT DIRECTION.
WHY NOT KEEP IT GOING?
ALL RIGHT, JUAN.
WHY CAN'T YOU JUST ADMIT IT
WORKS WHEN WE SHAKE HANDS AND
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT SEGMENT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL DAY.
LET'S HAVE FUN IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND LET'S NOT TALK
POLITICS, LET'S JUST SHUT UP.
I WAS WONDERING WHEN YOU WERE
SHOWING THE CLIPS, GREG, I
THOUGHT IT'S PRETTY CLEAR HE
MANUFACTURED THIS DEAL.
YOU KNOW.
IT SEEMS TO ME HE SAYS WITHOUT
GETTING MEXICO TO AGREE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP THE ASYLUM
PEOPLE, HE SAYS "WE'VE GOT A
DEAL AND THERE IS SOME SECRET TO
IT AND THE MEXICANS SAY "NO
SECRET" SO MAYBE GREG IS SEEING
SOMETHING I'M NOT SEEING.
I HOPE THIS IS NOT "I BACK
TRUMP, YOU DON'T" BUT I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING THAT MEXICO
CONCEDED.
LOOKS TO ME TRUMP GOT ROLLED.
>> I STRONGLY DISAGREED.
THEY AGREED TO SEND 500 TROOPS
TO THEIR SOUTHERN BORDER, NOW
6,000 TROOPS AND IF YOU'RE
SEEKING ASYLUM YOU STAY IN
MEXICO.
THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S PROGRESS, JUAN.
THE MEDIA HAS LIED ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SABOTAGE
ANY VICTORY HE HAS.
IF THERE IS NO NEW DEAL WHY DID
THE PRESIDENT OF MEXICO SAY WE
HAVE A NEW DEAL ON SATURDAY?
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> Juan: THANK YOU.
>> WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE WITH A FOREIGN POWER
IN ORDER TO FIX OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
NANCY PELOSI CAN SOLVE IT IN A
HEARTBEAT BUT SHE DOESN'T
BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO SECURE
POLITICAL POWER INSTEAD OF
SECURING THE COUNTRY.
HOW IS FLEXING ECONOMIC MUSCLE
TO GET WHAT YOU WANT BULLYING?
THAT'S AMERICA FIRST AND THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T LIKE THAT.
USUALLY THE MEDIA, WHEN THERE IS
A DEAL LIKE WE HAVE SEEN, NAFTA,
PARIS, IRAN OR BERGDAHL, THEY
PRAISE THESE BAD DEALS AND EVERY
TIME WE LOSE MONEY, POWER AND
FACE, THE MEDIA DON'T LIKE IT
BECAUSE IT'S GOOD FOR AMERICA.
>> Greg: THERE IS THIS ARGUMENT
THEY ALREADY AGREED TO IT BUT I
THINK THE TARIFFS PUSHED THEM
FASTER TO THE AGREEMENT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE THREAT
GOT THEM ON BOARD.
>> Dana: MAYBE INITIALLY.
I'M KICKING MYSELF BECAUSE
KIRSGEN NIELSEN, THE FORMER
SECRETARY WHO WAS FIRED,
RESIGNED, SHE HAD ORCHESTRATED
THIS DEAL WITH THE MEXICANS IN
ORDER TO SEND THE NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS AND MAKE THEM KEEP MORE
PEOPLE IN MEXICO AND MAYBE THE
DETAILS WEREN'T FINALIZED.
I FIND IT HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS EVER GOING TO
GO FORWARD WITH 25% TARIFFS
HEADING INTO AN ELECTION YEAR
WHEN THE ECONOMY IS HIS
STRONGEST POINT OF VIEW.
BUT I THINK THERE MIGHT BE SOME
THREE DIMENSIONAL UNDERWATER
CHESS GOING ON BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENED?
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW SAYING TARIFFS
ARE BAD.
NOW DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING, WAIT,
TARIFFS ARE A TAX ON CONSUMERS
AND BUSINESSES AND THIS IS WRONG
AND WE CAN'T HAVE THAT, AND I
THINK, WOW, NOW WE'VE REALLY GOT
THEM.
>> Greg: DEGAN, YOU ARE THE
BUSINESS PERSON HERE.
I WAS THINKING THAT TRUMP SEES
-- TRUMP I DON'T THINK IS IN TO
WAR.
I THINK HE'S KIND OF -- I THINK
FROM A FINANCIAL STANDPOINT HE
THINKS IT'S A WASTE OF BLOOD,
TREASURE AND JUST TIME.
I THINK HE SEES TRADE WARS AS
THE REPLACEMENT FOR WAR AND WHY
SHOULD -- ISN'T THAT PROGRESS?
>> I WILL CHOOSE TARIFFS OVER
VIOLENCE ANY DAY.
I THINK ANY OF US WOULD MAKE
THAT.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE SOME MIDDLE
GROUND AND I WILL PUT ON MY
TARIFF FACE WHICH IS -- THAT'S
MY TARIFF FACE.
HE'S DOING THIS BECAUSE HE USES
THESE BORDER TAXES TO PUSH BACK
ON MEXICO, AND THEN LEAVES THEM
UP IN THE AIR LIKE IF YOU DON'T
PLAY BALL I'M BRINGING THEM
BACK.
THAT DOES CREATE A LOT OF
BUSINESS UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
INVESTMENT AND GROWTH.
YOU HAVE MANUFACTURING IN THIS
COUNTRY LOOKING REALLY SOFT THIS
YEAR AND BUSINESSES -- DEERE,
GENERAL MOTORS, 3M ARE PULLING
BACK ON INVESTMENT, NOT HIRING,
EVEN POTENTIALLY LAYING OFF
PEOPLE SO IT INTRODUCES
UNCERTAINTY.
HE'S CALLED HIMSELF TARIFF MAN
AND TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD.
HE LIKES USING TARIFFS.
I LOOK AT IT LIKE A PRETEEN BOY
USING NUNCHUKS.
HE EVENTUALLY SMACKS HIMSELF IN
THE FACE.
THAT'S MAYBE WHERE THIS GOES.
HE NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THE
ECONOMY.
>> Greg: ON THE OTHER HAND YOU
MIGHT SEE CHINA GOING "HE REALLY
MEANS IT."
THIS COULD BE PROGRESS.
SPEAKING OF PROGRESS.
I PASSED MY DRIVER'S TEST.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Dana: EVERYONE HAS BEEN
WANTING TO KNOW.
>> Greg: I ONLY GOT ONE THING
WRONG.
>> Juan: WODIED?
>> Greg: I SCORED PERFECTLY
EXCEPT FOR ONE THING.
>> Dana: DID HE GIVE YOU A GOLD
STAR ON YOUR CHART?
>> Juan: DON S--
>> Greg: DON SCARDINO WAS MY
INSTRUCTOR.
>> WHAT DID HE NAIL YOU ON?
>> HE WAS THE INSTRUCTOR BUT
THEY HAVE THE TESTER.
YOU HAD TO DO A COMPLETE STOP
BUT THERE WAS A STREET COMING
DOWN HERE FROM THE SIDE AND
THERE WERE CARS AND I WANTED TO
GET OUT A LITTLE FURTHER AND YOU
ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO GET OUT
FURTHER.
>> YOU'RE TOO SHORT TO SEE OVER.
>> Greg: THAT WASN'T NECESSARY.
YOU SHOULD LET ME BASK IN MY
MOMENT.
>> Dana: HOW DID THE PICTURE
TURN OUT ON YOUR DRIVER'S
LICENSE?
>> Greg: I LOOK A LITTLE OLDER
THAN MY LAST ONE.
>> Dana: WE'VE GOT TO FIND IT.
>> THIS IS LIVE TV.
>> Dana: WE WANT TO SEE THE
PICTURE.
>> SHOW YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER.
>> YOU'RE UNDER ARREST.
THE GLASSES.
WHEN YOU TAKE IT OFF IT'S A
DISGUISE.
>> Dana: THERE I AM.
YOU GET TO SEE MY BEAUTIFUL
FINGERS.
THE PRODUCER SAID I LOOK CREEPY.
>> Dana: I WANT TO SEE --
>> NO.
>> Juan: IT'S LIKE -- EVERYBODY
LOOKS --
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY FOR THE
HEIGHT?
>> Dana: LET'S KEEP THAT
PRIVATE.
>> Greg: THIS IS OVER.
>> I'M NOT HERE EVERY DAY.
I'M SAYING NOTHING.
>> Dana: MY HEIGHT.
THERE IS A MISTAKE ON MINE.
NOT BECAUSE I SORT OF --
EXAGGERATED.
THERE IS A TYPO.
AND IT'S PRETTY FUNNY.
>> Juan: HOW LONG DOES IT LAST?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
FIVE YEARS?
>> 10.